like clockwork nba 2k launches every
september and reignites the age-old
debate of who's overrated who's
underrated and how the series's last
iteration feels according to the
passionate fandom
this year nba 2k23 muddies those waters
in an interesting way not only will
players take the court with modern
superstars like steph curry and kevin
durant they'll be able to travel back to
the 80s 90s and early 2000s and play as
legends like bird duncan and iverson for
more on these new features as well as
details on the nba 2k 23 release date
pre-order details and more here's
everything you need to know about nba
2k23
while annual sports sims typically have
few innovations outside of updated
rosters year to year it appears nba 2k
23 is poised to add several new features
to its suite of modes
nba 2k's most popular mode my player is
back
every year the team does a great job of
making your custom character the star of
the game and a new storyline in this
year's game will do that once more
this time the story starts with you
actually getting to choose your own
landing spot via the nba draft while
that may sound great
there's a catch the team's fanbase
wanted a different player so you'll be
tasked with winning over your new fan
base when they've got wandering eyes for
your rival shep owens from being booed
on stage at the draft to exploring the
city and seeing fans wearing owen's
jersey rather than yours the environment
will be hostile at first but winning
solves everything doesn't it throughout
the storyline you'll work to gain the
fan's admiration and prove over the
course of your career that you were the
right pick all along the team of visual
concepts says this year's my player is
the biggest the team has ever done and
the story will include cameos as it
often does including rapper baz and
music producer elite both of whom work
under j cole's label dreamville records
next up is my nba eras this year's my
nba mode which is the series take on a
seasons long franchise mode lets players
jump backwards in time across four
distinct starting points 1983 1992 2002
or present day these years weren't
picked at random they each represent a
season immediately preceding nba drafts
that forever changed the sport in 1983
you'll start a year before michael
jordan was drafted in 1992 you'll tip
off one season before shaq arrives to
forever change how big's play in the
league in 2002 you'll begin just before
recent and modern stars such as lebron
james and dwayne wade made their debuts
the studio is calling these the magic
verse bird era the jordan era and the
kobe era respectively in this mode
players can alter the past and future of
the nba forever
trade magic johnson to the bucks or make
the mistake of drafting michael jordan
with the celtics when he belongs with
the bulls the choices are yours to make
and your actions will ripple out over
the years to come as you play season
after season you'll even be able to
rewrite the nba history books by making
it so maybe jordan doesn't retire for
two years in the middle of this run for
six nba titles repeating the three-peat
like in the typical my mba mode you can
keep it realistic and execute fair
trades for the players you want to move
or you can turn off cpu tray logic and
move players around the league like
you're redecorating your kitchen the
rule books and players playing styles
will all be accurate to their respective
times even the player's shorts will be
respective of their era from the short
shorts of the 80s to the iverson era
long baggy shorts to today's style
landing somewhere in between
speaking of jordan and the bulls the
jordan challenge will be returning for
the first time since its debut in nba
2k11. this time it's growing in size
from 10 challenges to 15 but also in how
immersive the mode will be like in my
nba eras reliving jordan's games from
the 80s and 90s will include visual
filters and other touches to put players
in the right time and place
period-specific arenas and
advertisements as well as old-fashioned
broadcasts right down to the on-screen
scoreboard and exclusive commentary
teams are all included this includes
classic games like jordan's final last
dance game of 1998 against the utah jazz
along with going all the way back to his
college years with his 1982 ncaa
national championship game unc versus
georgetown each challenge will be
accompanied by talking head segments
that use real interviews the visual
concepts team conducted for the game
mode to help contextualize the
importance of each playable reenactment
they include interviews with people such
as marv albert commentator for the shrug
game rival kareem abdul-jabbar former
teammate dennis rodman coach phil
jackson and more personally as someone
who grew up with the bulls during the
jordan era this is the mode i'm most
looking forward to while all of these
historical modes sound like a blast the
real question is if the encore gameplay
will hold up to this end visual concepts
believes it's figured out the cure for
what ailed last year's perimeter heavy
game new shooting mechanics will create
more separation between the game's
mediocre shooters and its elite marksman
meaning you'll need to play well at all
levels on offense and won't be able to
simply rely on hitting open shots
meanwhile a greater sense of power and
paint dominance should give players more
ways to win than just draining threes
like the warriors apparently this year's
game is inspired by the way giannis
adekompo plays with his aggressive
slashing style according to nba 2k
gameplay director mike wang the team has
expanded on tools meant to attack the
basket the team is set out to improve
its pro stick giving players more
maneuverability you'll be able to
perform new gesture combos like double
throws and switchbacks meant to provide
shooting windows in tight quarters the
double throw gesture is meant to help
hop step layups while the switchback
gestures are used for euro step and
cradle layups
nba 2k 23 releases on playstation xbox
switch and pc on september 9th like most
sports games your choice of which
version to pick up consists of several
different editions with each pricier one
growing in its added content all the way
up to a sold out version that includes a
year of nba league pass which grants
live access to all nba games all season
long for 60 dollars you can pick up the
standard last gen version of nba 2k 23
while current gen will cost you 70
meanwhile the digital deluxe edition of
nba 2k 23 which includes my team points
tokens promo packs and more will cost 80
for 100 you'll be able to net the
michael jordan edition which includes
yet more bonus content finally there's
the championship edition which will cost
150
the main draw here is the 12 month nba
league pass subscription which gives you
access to live games throughout the year
considering the nba league pass costs 15
per month this isn't a bad option if
you're a big nba fan and want the league
pass either way
granted it is currently sold out
and there you have everything you need
to know about the upcoming nba 2k23
make sure to come back for our full
review of nba 2k 23 next week for more
on nba 2k 23 and all things games make
sure to stay tuned to gamespot and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you